A boatful of creepy creatures from RL Stine's
Goosebumps books are brought to life on the
big screen in the movie Goosebumps, which
stars Jack Black as the famous horror writer.
I'm Jan and this is 10 things you probably
didn't know about Goosebumps.
To bring the movie's zombie-like Ghouls to
life, eight actors had custom-made flesh-coloured
prosthetics applied to their faces.
The ghoulish face prosthetics were made from
medical-grade silicone.
Each set of prosthetics took a whole day to
make, and the actors playing the Ghouls each
needed a new set applied every day.
As for the Ghouls' long fingers, 1500 of those
were made by hand, then hand-painted and brushed
with clear nail polish.
Unlike the facial prosthetics, each prosthetic
finger could be used three times.
From getting their prosthetics applied to
dressing in hand-tailored vintage clothes,
it took each Ghoul three and a half hours
to get ready.
Several of the actors playing the Ghouls already
had plenty of experience playing zombies as
they'd worked on the TV show The Walking Dead.
If you're wondering what the hair department
used to make Professor Shock's hair stand
up on end, it was actually laundry detergent!
To bring to life Slappy the Dummy, RL Stine's
alter ego in the movie, a ventriloquist's
dummy was made by Californian effects firm
Ironhead Studio, whose creature and costume
design has featured in The Avengers, Godzilla,
and The Hunger Games: Mockingjay.
Director Rob Letterman wanted Slappy's face
to resemble Jack Black in the movie as Black
plays RL Stine and also does Slappy's voice.
On set, puppeteer Avery L Jones controlled
Slappy's movements, and scenes where Slappy
walks were later enhanced with computerised
effects.
According to young stars Dylan Minnette, Odeya
Rush and Ryan Lee, the movie's creepiest creation
was the Clown, especially because the actor
playing him never broke character on set!
To turn performer Vivian Kyle into the Snake
Lady, it took around 3 hours, which included
applying face and chest prosthetics, airbrushing
her hands, and fitting her skin-tight metallic
dress.
The Snake Lady's eyes were made from polarised
sunglass lenses, and could be popped out easily
during breaks in filming.
As for her wig, that took three people 90
hours to make.
The Bog Monster, who's known as the Swamp
Monster in author RL Stine's books, was a
late addition to the movie.
Creature Special Effects Designer Stephen
Prouty created the costume by hand-sewing
thread that's used for camouflage hunting
uniforms on to fabric netting.
Actor Nate Andrade, who plays the Bog Monster,
is 6 foot 8 inches tall and, in real life,
is actually married to Vivian Kyle who plays
The Snake Lady!
The Egyptian Priestess's eyebrows are made
up of hieroglyphics which spell the word “Goosebumps”.
The ice-laden wigs worn by the movie's frozen
people were made by painting wigs with white
and clear caulking or sealant from a hardware
store.
It took four weeks to create fourteen wigs
which matched the actors' own hairstyles.
As for the icicles that hang from the frozen
people's faces, they were made using clear
acrylics and vacuum-formed plastic.
Although the movie's werewolf is a computer-generated
creation, rather than a practical effect,
a stunt performer acted out some of its moves
to give the filmmakers a point of reference
for how the creature might act.
According to visual effects supervisor Erik
Nordby, the most difficult creature to create
was an evil poodle, which only appears in
six shots in the movie.
The reason it was so challenging is that it's
extremely tough to make its tightly coiled
fur look real in CGI.
In fact, it took the visual effects team four
to five months to perfect its appearance.
Now, let me know in the comments below, who
are your favourite characters in Goosebumps?
And which are your favourite books in the
series?
If you enjoyed this video, do please share
it, hit the thumbs-up button and subscribe
for loads more things you didn't know, as
well as movie reviews and interviews.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!